forget these guys come on
there's only one way over there raptor
must be up ahead
however it looks like but there's a ton
of enemies if we're gonna do this
we'll have to you still had one stage to
go in your exit yeah but what's that
how about we make this the are you sure
that's how it's a custom version of the
exam
besides so what do you say
prepare for takeoff raptor awaits you
once you defeat all these enemies
then that gliding license is yours
[Music]
right
right
nice you breezed through it
you're a natural i knew you'd be fine
all that's left now is to grab ourselves
a raptor let's go
huh
uh
ah
bet you can't keep up with me
[Music]
huh
huh
yes
[Music]
huh
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
no one escapes my sights
it looks like there's no way across oh
he must be your amber
over there
if you insist on chasing me so be it you
must be
i don't need to escape oh it oh
little girl why don't you run along hey
watch it you're talking to a knights of
fevonius outrider
so how did he get across
can you see anything bye-bye oh no
we can't hesitate but but don't worry
i'm the gliding
boy outrider
sees your point remember that book i
lent you the one i thought was
the first birds couldn't fly be my wit
raptor says i'll wait stop raptor says
i'll never make the wind
amber no you're gonna fall you're gonna
fall it's a wind
current she she's gliding amber's
sliding
crazy kid you must have known about the
wind current
there's no way you would have jumped
otherwise
the wind takes care of those who have
courage now sit still and await your
arrest
here's something special yeah
wind blade just a temporary
set all right i got him i only noticed
the wind current from in the air
and it would be suicide in other words
the only way
aha so he was little did he know we're
not it was all thanks to your sharp
thinking
just like a wise man at the end of the
day gliding a seven parts technique
what you did now looked more uh it was
just like in my first gliding exam
i was super nervous i kind of missed
that nervous um
sorry my mom thought you said you passed
no problem uh
well you see the thing is every time i
get my license but i
always pass the first time i guess my
little glide let's go and get a copy of
the real gliding manual
from acting grandmaster i'll head off
first because i need to escort
once you're back in the city don't
forget to come
ah she just can't sit still can she
guess that's why she's the outrider
when this is all done and dusted let's
head to the cathedral in monstart
ah getting this gliding license has
turned into quite the adventure
[Music]
ah
ah
yep
congratulations here is your gliding
license i'm not surprised though
you are a natural after all
oh and i'll sign you up for the next
wind gliding champion
i glide so fast that no one can keep up
it's just me up there
on my own gliding around oh
fighting talk it well until i kick your
butt in the chat
make sure you obey the rules whatever
you oh brother
if you ask
[Music]